فصلت قوته الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عشرت
فلسطينيين واصابت مئه بجروح خلال اقتحامها
مدينه نابلس الاربعاء وقد نددت سلطه
الفلسطينيه بهذا العدوان وطالبت واشنطن
بالضغط على تل ابيب لوقفه بينما هددت
فصائل فلسطينيه بالرد عليه بجانبها قالت
الامم المتحده ان التوتر في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه بلغ اعلى مستوياته منذ سنوات
وانه يهدد استقرار المنطقه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله اقدام قوات
الاحتلال على اقتحام مدينه نابلس بهذه
القسوه وايقاعها كل هذه الخسائر بين
الفلسطينيين وما واجهت ربط ذلك بظروف التي
تواجهها حكومه اليمين المتطرف في تل ابيب
ما خيارات السلطه الفلسطينيه للتعامل مع
التصعيد الاسرائيلي لمتزايد في الضفه وما
مغزى استمراره رغم سحب السلطه مسوده قرار
في مجلس الامن يدين اسرائيل ما هو الدور
الامريكي المحتمل لاحتوائه هذا التصعيد لا
سيما بعد تحذير فصائل فلسطينيه من نفاذ
صبرها وتاكيد الامم المتحده وصول التوتر
الى ذروه الى ذروه وبلوغه مرحله تهديد
استقرار المنطقه
[موسيقى]
في سياق تصعيد اسرائيلي مستمر منذ اشهر
توالت التحذيرات من احتمال ارتفاع وتيرته
بوصول حكومه اليمين المتطرف الى السلطه في
تل ابيب نهايه العام الماضي اوقعت قواته
الاحتلال عشره شهداء فلسطينيين وجرحت اكثر
من 100 وصفت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه حالات
بعضهم بالخطيره اثناء اقتحامها مدينه
نابلس يوم الاربعاء بذريعه اعتقال مطلوبين
مصادر طبيه فلسطينيه قالت ان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منعت وصول تواقم
الاسعاف الى المصابين ان ثلاثه صحفيين
اصيبوا بالرصاص الحي خلال تغطيتهم
الاقتحام وقد اندلعت اشتباكات مسلحه بين
مقاومين فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال خلال
تصعيدها الذي شمل ايضا تنفيذ اعتقالات في
رام الله وطول كرم والخليل والقدس
[موسيقى]
انقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من رام الله
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره للوطنيه الفلسطينيه من واشنطن
الدكتور بريد بوينت المدير السابق للتعاون
والانخراط الدولي لحل الازمات في البيت
الابيض ومن نيويورك عبد الحميد الصيام
الخبير في شؤون الامم المتحده مرحبا بكم
جميعا دكتور مصطفى بماذا يخبرك هذا الهدوء
هذا الهجوم عفوا بشراسته في نابلس
يخبرنا بثلاثه اشياء اولا هذه مجزره
بربريه وحشيه جيش الاحتلال استخدم فيها
الرصاص الحي ضد مدنيين عزل ولذلك لم يسقط
فقط عشره شهداء ارتقوا وانما بعضهم كان
يعني هناك اطفال وهناك شيخ مسن الذي
رايناه وحشيه بربريه غير مسبوقه
ومئه وسته اشخاص اصيبوا ايضا بالرصاص الحي
وبعضهم سته او سبعه قد يستشهدوا في اي
لحظه نحن نتحدث عن اجرام غير مسبوق
لم يكن ليجري لولا الامر الثاني وهو الصمت
الدولي على هذه الجرائم الاسرائيليه
والخطا الفاحش الكبير الذي ارتكب بسحب
قرار من مجلس الامن من قبل السلطه
الفلسطينيه وهذا لم يكن يجب ان يحدث ويجب
ان يعتذر على ما جرى ويجب ان يعادل الامر
الى مجلس الامن فورا
والعمر الثالث الذي رايناه بطوله هائله
شباب واهل نابلس جبل النار الذي صمد دوما
لكل هذا القمع والتنكيل هؤلاء الشباب
الابطال تصدوا بصدورهم العاريه لجيش
الاحتلال الذي جاء بمدرعاته واسلحته وجيشه
المدجج ووقفوا في وجهه حمايه لوطنهم
وحمايه للمقاومين وحمايه لبلدهم نابلس
ولكن ما رايناه مجدره وحشيه ضد مدنيين
اصابوا بالرصاص الحي 3 صحفيين اطلقوا
الرصاص على المسعفين اطلقوا الرصاص على
السيارات الاسعاف منعوا المسعفين من
الوصول الى الجرحى هذه مجزره بالمعنى
الحرفي للكلمه لو جرت في اي مكان اخر في
العالم لسمعنا الان الادانات بالعشرات
تتوالى من كل دول العالم من الولايات
المتحده والدول الغربيه وغيرها ولكننا حتى
الان لم نسمع شيئا الادانات فقط
للفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين يسمح لهم بان
يكونوا فوق القانون الدولي دون محاسبه
ودون مسائله في هذا السياق اذا سمحت لي
اسال اسال الدكتور ابراهيم قبل ايام اشاره
بايدن الى ان مئه وثلاثه واربعين دوله
ادانت الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا اكثر من
هذا العدد بكثير تدين الممارسات
الاسرائيليه بحق الفلسطينيين ومع هذا
اسرائيل تستخدم او عفوا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تستخدم حق النقد الفيتو لعدم
ادانه اسرائيل الا
يعني يخل هذا بمصداقيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التي تسعى كما تقول الى حل
الدولتين
ان اعبر عن
اسفي وحزني لعائلات هؤلاء الذين فقدوا
حياتهم او جرحوا هذا يجعل من الرئيس بايدن
وفريقه في موقف صعب للغايه ومن كل صراحه
اقول هذا امر كان متوقعا راينا رئيس
الوزراء
نتنياهو وحكومته وهم ياتون الى سده الحكم
وهم محملون
بهذا الكم الهائل من السياسات بحق
الفلسطينيين هذا الان يضعوا في الصداره
التوتر الموجود داخل
مراكز صناعه القرار الامريكيه هذا امر يجب
حله على رئيس
بايدن ان يتخلى عن موقفه تفرج وعليه ان
يجز سبلًا من شانها ان يوصل صوته الى رئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو بان مثل هذه
التصرفات غير مقبوله وانا لا المتحده تكون
مستعده ليس فقط للحديث عن هذه الامور بل
اتخاذ الخطوات وارسلان رساله واضحه
للحكومه الاسرائيليه بان مثل هذا النوع من
الاستفزازات وهذا النوع من فقدان اناس
كثيرين لحياتهم لا يمكن السكوت عنه عليهم
ان يغيروا موقفهم
طبعا اشار الدكتور البرغوثي الى ما سماها
خطيئه سحب مسوده القرار من مجلس الامن قبل
قليل سمعنا المندوب الفلسطيني يتحدث بانه
سيعقد اجتماعا لسفراء العرب لمناقشه
التحرك من قبل مجلس الامن هل هذا يعني
بالضروره عوده الى طرح مسوده القرار هذا
شكرا جلال يعني اولا اريد ان اقدم تعازي
لاهالي الشهداء واتمنى للجرحى سرعه
التعافي واؤكد ان الشعب الفلسطيني كله يقف
معهم وان هذه الفئه التي تنسق امنيا مع
القوات الصهيونيه هي فئه معزوله لا تمثل
الشعب الفلسطيني اود ان اؤكد انه ما كان
يمكن ان يحدث هذا بهذه الفضاعه وفي وفي عز
النهار وعاده يقومون بغاراتهم في الليل
الا بعد ان تراجعت السلطه الفلسطينيه عن
مشروع القرار وتم تغيير اللغه بشكل غير
مقبول على الاطلاق كان هناك نصف المشروع
القرار يقول بادانه الاستيطان ووقفه فورا
تغير هذا النص ليحدث عن الانزعاج من
الاستيطان
واعتباره فقط عقبه في طريق السلام ثم
الاخطر من ذلك انه اقحمت فقره
مشروع البيان يطالب السلطه الفلسطينيه
بالتخلي عن الارهاب ليس فقط اداره التخلي
وكانها جزء منه ثم يطالب بمقاومه الارهاب
موجود كلمه اي مقاومه
الارهاب اي ان هذا هو دور السلطه مقاومه
الارهاب والتخلي عن الارهاب وبه في التالي
في هذا الجو تقدمت اسرائيل بهذه العنجويه
وسط النهار مدعومه بمعلومات مؤكده حول
بنايه فيها بعض النشطاء ويتم قصفها
بصواريخ ليس فقط باسلحه ناريه عاديه بل
بصواريخ لتقتل هذا العدد الكبير من الناس
اذا هذه التحركات في مجلس الامن والتحركات
المجموعه العربيه للاسف عندما وصلت هاتف
فقط تليفون من بلنكن الى محمود عباس تغير
كل شيء وسحب مشروع القرار وتغيرت لغته
وهبطت الى هذا يمكن ان يعود هذا السؤال
يجب
يمكن ان يعود الى مجلس الامن بارتضاب لو
سمحت
هذا مستحيل هذه فرصه وضعت كان ممكن ان
يتقدم مشروع القرار والتصويت عليه ولياخذ
فيتو من الولايات هذا سيكون الفيتو رقم 46
لماذا يخشون الفيتو الامريكي طب هذه
النقطه مصطفى لماذا لا تريد امريكا ان
تستخدم الفيتو الان ربما ساعود اليك دكتور
مصطفى اذا ما فائده هذا القرار انت وصلت
بان سحبه خطيئه وخطا كبير بالنسبه لفلسطين
ولكن قال لك سيد صيام الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ستستعمل الفيتو ولن يمر مشروع
القرار هذا اذا ما الفائده
اولا انا برايي مش بس خطيئه والسلطه
الفلسطينيه مطالبه بان تعتذر للشعب
الفلسطيني عن هذه الخطيئه لانها اصلا لم
تشرح للشعب الفلسطيني لماذا سحبت هذا
القرار
نحن بدنا نخلي الولايات المتحده تاخذ فيتو
تعمل فيتو عشان تنكشف الكذب الكبرى التي
يواصلون فيها الحديث عن حل الدولتين
واسرائيل تذبح حل الدولتين بالاستيطان
ليوضع العالم امام مسؤولياته كلمه وشعار
حل الدولتين اصبحت مخرج لكل الدول الغربيه
للهروب من مسؤولياتها بضروره فرض العقوبات
على اسرائيل بضروره وقف هذه الازدواجيه في
المعايير الدوليه المجزره التي وقعت اليوم
في نابلس وقبلها مجزره جنين في بلد اخر
مثل ايرلندا كانت تعتبر مجزره لمع لا يعني
لا يمكن السكوت عليها نفس الشيء في جنوب
افريقيا وهي من حيث الحجم لا تقل عن ذلك
وم الملك يصمتون نحن اردنا ان تحرج
الولايات المتحده حتى تقول ان كانت فعلا
مع حل فلسطيني تقوم فيه دوله فلسطينيه وحل
الدولتين
فلتفرض عقوبات على اسرائيل اما ان تضع
فيتو على قرار يدين الاستيطان الذي تعتبره
مدمر لقيام دوله فلسطينيه مستقله فهذا
يكون انكشاف كامل للنفاق الدولي بالتالي
المطلوب اليوم ان يطرح سؤال كيف يمكن ردع
اسرائيل كيف يمكن وقف هذه الهجمات
البربريه من حكومه لا يمكن ان توصف الا
بانها فاشيه يقودها بنج فيروس متريتش الحل
الوحيد ليس الا المقاومه الفلسطينيه على
الارض وفرض العقوبات والمقاطعه على
اسرائيل لن ترضع اسرائيل الا بالمقاومه
وفرض العقوبات عليها طيب السلطه
الفلسطينيه التي سحبت لتوها قرارا في مجلس
الامن الدولي يدين اسرائيل بعدما قيل انها
جهود امريكيه للتهدئه بين الفلسطينيين وتل
ابيب طالبت على الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
الاداره الامريكيه بالتحرك فورا والضغط
الفاعل على الحكومه الاسرائيليه لوقف
مسمتها جرائمها بدورها دانه الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه الاقتحام الدموي لمدينه نابلس
وصفته بانه ارهاب دوله منظم وتصعيد خطير
في ساحه
الصراع دكتور اعود اليك انت قلت بان اداره
بايدن الان محرجه امام هذا الاقتحام
الدموي من اسرائيل بحق الفلسطينيين ويسال
الدكتور البرغوثي والسيد صيام ماذا بامكان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تفعل وهي
التي تضغط على الجانب الفلسطيني ليتراجع
عن بعض خطواته ماذا يمكن ان تفعل وكيف
يمكن ان تضغط على حكومه نتنياهو لوقف هذا
القتل العشوائي في الطرقات وفي الشوارع
الفلسطينيه
اعتقد ان عليه من يفعلوا ذلك والسؤال هو
هل سيفعلون ذلك ام لا من جهه هناك
الكثير من الضغوط السياسيه الداخليه هنا
في الولايات المتحده
لاستمرار الدعم القوي لاسرائيل لكن هذا لا
يعني ان بايدن ليس لديه اي هامش للمناوره
وانه لا يستطيع ان يبدا بسحب بعض عناصر
الدعم السياسي او حتى بعض العناصر الدعم
الدبلوماسي وان ذلك سيبدا بارسال رساله
الى رئيس الوزراء دعونا لا ننسى ايضا
ان هناك حاله من الاستياء في صفوف المجتمع
الاسرائيلي نفسه ازاء بعض التغيرات التي
الحكومته احداثها في النظام القضائي اذا
الولايات المتحده عليها ان تتراجع وان
تبين نوع من التباين بين موقف واشنطن وبين
حكومه نتنياهو هذا سيكون مهما سياسيا
لنتنياهو على نتنياهو ان يكون حذرا هنا
لانه اذا بدا
بالحاق المزيد من الضرر بالعلاقه مع
امريكا سيبدا بالشعور اكثر فاكثر
بالعزله
وربما نتنياهو تمادى كثيرا هنا وفي
الساعات والايام المقبله قد نرى محاوله
لتعديل وتخفيف بعض مواقفه ربما
فرض بعض المعايير بحيث لا يتكرر ما حدث
اليوم هذا تصيد الاسرائيلي في الضفه
والقدس دفع الامين من الامم المتحده
انطونيو غوتارش للتحذير من ان التوتر في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله بلغ اعلى
مستوياته منذ سنوات ونوبات يهدد الاستقرار
في جميع انحاء المنطقه وفي خارجها وفي
الداخل الفلسطيني قالت حركه الجهاد
الاسلاميه التي استشهد قائد جناحها
العسكري في نابلس يوم الاربعاء ان العدوان
الاسرائيلي على نابلس يدل على مدى
الاستخفاف بكل ما يجري الحديث عنه من
تحركات سياسيه وتفاهمات اما كتائب القسام
في غزه فقط حذرت من ان صبرها اخذ في
النفاذ واكدت انها تراقب مسمته جرائم
العدو المتصاعده تجاه الاهالي في الضفه
المحتله بينما دعت مجموعات عارين الاسود
في نابلس كوادرها الى الاستعداد للرد على
ما سمتها جرائم الاحتلال اذا القلق الاممي
ليس فقط على فلسطين محتله انما على
المنطقه لا يوجد وسيله بالنسبه للاونم
المتحده بان تتحرك امام هذا الانحياز
الامريكي الواضح
لاسرائيل في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
للاسف استطيع ان اقول بشيء من الثقه ان
الامم المتحده تعطي غطاء لهذه الجرائم
حصلت مذبحه جنين ومذبحه اريحا ومذبحه
اليوم السيد طورونسلاند ممثل الامين العام
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله ومنسق
عمليه السلام لم يصدر اي بيان لا في مذبحه
جنين ولا مذبحه اريحا ولا اليوم واليوم
اسال المتحدث الرسمي لماذا لم يصدر بيانا
وهناك طفلان قتل اليوم مسنان ايضا هذه
الامم المتحده لا تستطيع ان تتحرك الا
باذن من ضوء اخضر من الدول الكبرى تتحرك
بشكل متسارع وقوي في موضوع اوكرانيا اليوم
الساعه الثالثه اي بعد ساعتين ستعقد
الجمعيه العامه
اجتماعنا على مستوى الوزراء حول اوكرانيا
ويوم الجمعه كذلك مجلس الامس سيجتمع على
اوكرانيا منذ بدات الحرب الاوكرانيه لا
عمل للامم المتحده الا اوكرانيا لكن تحدث
هذه المجازر ويعبرون عن القلق احيانا فقط
وليس دائما لم يصدر حتى بيان اليوم عن
مجازر اليوم للتعبير عن القلق فقط هذه
الامم المتحده يجب ان يتم التعامل معها
بطريقه مختلفه هناك قرار اعتمد في مجلس
الامن رقم 904 عام
1994 بعد مجزره الحرم الابراهيمي ينص على
تامين الحمايه للشعب الفلسطيني
وسحب الاسلحه من المستوطنين هذا قرار يجب
على الامم المتحده ان تنفذه لو كان هناك
مجموعه عربيه متجانسه وقويه وصلبه تقوم
للامير العام نفذ هذا القرار هو لا يحتاج
الى الرجوع لاحد لان القرار اعتمد وهناك
قرارات اخرى تتعلق بالحمايه هناك قرار
اعتمد في الانتفاضه الاولى كذلك 640 يطالب
بحمايه الفلسطينيين الامين العام قدم
تقري تقريرا للجمعيه العامه يتحدث عن
ثلاثه خيارات لحمايه الشعب الفلسطيني اين
تلك الخيارات لذلك
المشكله فينا نحن المشكله في اولا قياده
الشعب الفلسطيني ثم المجموعه العربيه التي
تفسخت بعضها ينسق ويحتفل
بما يسمى استقلال اسرائيل اسرائيليين هذا
هو الوضع الذي نعيشه الان بالحديث دائما
عن الخيارات دكتور ماذا تفهم من اعلان
فصائل فلسطينيه نفاد صبرها
دكتور مصطفى
مش بس الفصائل الفلسطينيه نفذ صبرها الشعب
الفلسطيني كله نفس صدره ولذلك طبعا سيكون
هناك ردود فعل على هذه الجريمه البربريه
وهذه المجزره الوحشيه ودعني اقول بكل وضوح
هناك قناعه عميقه لدى الشعب الفلسطيني
باننا لا يجب ان ننتظر المساعده من احد في
الخارج علينا ان نعتمد على نفسنا على
مقاومتنا على نضالنا وعلى كفاحنا هذا
متغلغل بصوره عميقه في وعي كل شاب فلسطيني
اليوم ولذلك اذا قام الفلسطينيون بردود
افعال طبعا سنسمع ادانات من هذا المجتمع
الدولي الصامت الان على مجازر اسرائيل
البربريه الاهم من ذلك ماذا يمكن ان نطلب
من العالم اولا يجب ان يوجه سؤال لكل
الدول والحكومات التي اقدمت على تطبيع
مشين مع هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه المجرمه
بان عليها ان توقف هذا التطبيق هذا راي
شعوبها وليس راينا فقط وعلينا ان نطالب
الان بفرض العقوبات والمقاطعه ايجابيا
ودوليا وبعد ذلك الشعب الفلسطيني كفيل بان
يخوض نضاله وكفيل بان يناضل من اجل قضيته
وكفيل بان يتصدى لهذا الاجرام الذي يتعرض
له لكن ان تستمر عمليات التطبيع مع
اسرائيل ويستمر هذا الصمت المريب على هذه
الجرائم الوحشيه هذا امر غير مقبول ولا
يمكن ان نسمح بان يستمر باي حال من
الاحوال سؤال الاخير يا دكتور برين في
واشنطن بدقيقه واحده لو سمحت الحديث دائما
بان الرسائل الامريكيه لحكومه نتنياهو
اليمنيه المتطرفه غير كافيه يجب اتخاذ
خطوات عملاتيه هل هذا الهجوم الذي قلت
بانه يحرج اداره بايدن ممكن ان تضعه في
هذا الاتجاه في اتجاه بان يتم فرض ربما
عقوبات او تخفيف التعامل مع هذه الحكومه
التوتر في الاراضي الفلسطينيه باقتضاب لو
سمحت
واحده من الامور القويه حول الحرب في
اوكرانيا هي كيف اننا عشنا هذه التجربه من
خلال صور واشرطه فيديو لم نراها من قبل لا
اعتقد اننا يمكن ان نسقط من الحساب كما
نرى نحن في الوقت المتحده ما حدث
والخسائر الفاضحه في الارواح هذا لابد وان
يكون له اثر وتاثير وهذا سيفرض الضغوط
الاضافيه على الرئيس بادن وفريقه وراينا
بصراحه
ايضا كيف ان كيف ان
الطريقه التي تعاملت بها حكومه نتنياهو
وسياسه اسرائيل بطريقه لينه وسهله هذه
اللحظه ستكون ربما لحظه تغيير المسار شكرا
لك الدكتور في واشنطن الدكتور مصطفى البر
في رام الله والسيد عبد الحميد الصيام في
نيويورك شكرا لكم جميعا الى هنا ينتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء بامر الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]